welcome back i want to bring you some
breaking news regarding the situation in
the united states
in the minneapolis um you'll know if
you've been watching the coverage over
the last few days that there have been
protests after the death of an unarmed
black man
in police custody on monday a police
officer was filmed kneeling on the neck
of george floyd 46 years old
despite him saying that he couldn't
breathe and then mr floyd
eventually died and there have been four
police officers that mr floyd's family
have demanded face murder charges
for police officers they say implicated
in this death we're hearing in the last
few minutes
the minnesota public safety commissioner
has said that the minneapolis police
says a minneapolis police officer has
been taken into custody
in regards to the death of george floyd
that's according to various media
reports in the united states
so mr floyd's family had previously
wanted four police officers implicated
in his death to face murder charges but
the latest we're hearing is that
a police officer we don't know who has
been taken into custody
in relation to the death of george floyd